[Musique]
au moment où nous avons entendu parler de ce qui
se passait dans le Sud, nous avons tous
compris qu'ils avaient besoin d'un endroit où être,
pas pour une thérapie, juste pour être
ensemble pour s'asseoir pour manger quelque chose à
boire du café à boire  euh euh de la soupe pour faire de l'
art, pour peindre, pour jouer de la
musique et il y a toutes sortes de thérapeutes
ici et toutes sortes de bénévoles qui viennent pour la
plupart de la communauté trans
et de la communauté des festivals
[Musique]
et dans
traa, le corps est réparé et nous avons besoin
de beaucoup de bases, donc c'est ce que nous
faisons
[Musique]
ici, c'est important pour moi d'être ici
parce que je veux aider, je veux faire
quelque chose et c'est ce que je fais, je suis  en tant que
thérapeute, ça m'aide aussi à sentir que
j'aide l'État, c'est très très
confus, le bien-être et tout ce que c'est, c'est
compliqué, ce qui se passe ici,
donc voilà, c'est ce qui est si
beau en Israël, les civils, les
communautés  ici, c'est incroyable en une
minute, tout le monde aime se porter volontaire pour faire
quelque chose, donc ma responsabilité est envers
les gens qui sont dans le parti mais il y
a des gens qui sont responsables des
soldats ou des chiens qui vivent
là-bas ou des chats ou des enfants ou
pour
[Musique]
tout
et nous venons juste de commencer à recevoir des dons de
citoyens privés, venez
jeter un oeil, c'est absolument fou donc
c'est euh
environ peut-être un dixième de ce que nous avons de ce que nous
avons, nous nous en foutons si c'est  un
chien palestinien, peu nous importe si c'est un
chien israélien, nous pensons que
la vie des Palestiniens compte, la vie des Israéliens compte, nous
pensons que toutes les vies comptent, que vous marchiez
sur deux ou quatre pieds, que vous ayez des
ailes ou que cela n'a pas
d'importance.  J'avais juste l'impression que je devais faire
quelque chose, vous savez, tout le monde
recrute pour faire sa part, donc c'est
mon rôle en tant que
vétérinaire [Musique]
[Musique]
donc nous sommes comme une entreprise, c'est une
entreprise vieille d'une semaine mais elle a euh très bon  le contrôle
de toutes les euh missions que nous avons les
besoins la logistique euh c'est juste incroyable
vous y irez on dirait
qu'Amazon
notre gouvernement euh a très mal échoué tout
le pays actuel ne fonctionne pas
et nous sommes maintenant euh les remplaçant nous sommes
le  le système fonctionne donc nous essayons de
dire oui à toute demande qui
nous vient, nous essayons toujours de dire oui pour
tout, pas non et nous trouvons les moyens
d'obtenir la réponse à
chaque demande que nous
[Musique]
recevons
[  Musique]
mais c'était, vous savez, pendant la
manifestation, cela appartient au passé.
Samedi, nous avons réalisé que
le ciel est en train de tomber, quelque chose a
changé et de l'organisation qui
s'occupe de la manifestation, nous devons changer
pour devenir comme un  sauver euh une
organisation ou euh ce besoin de
fournir de
l'aide [Musique]
ouais, c'est
sûr que la plupart d'entre nous le
feront